5,524 plus 0.
Well, I'm adding 0.
I'm adding nothing, so it's
still just going to be 5,524.
By what number can we
multiply 8,895 to get 1?
Well, we're going to
have to multiply it
times its reciprocal.
So we're going to
multiply it times--
or we could say its
multiplicative inverse is
sometimes one way of
thinking about it.
And that's just
going to be 1/8,895.
You multiply 8,895
times 1/8,895,
you are going to get 1.
1,555 times 1.
Well, anything times 1 is
going to be that anything,
so this is essentially
saying one 1,555.
So that's just
going to be 1,555.
1,543 plus 0.
Well, we're adding
nothing to it,
so it's just going to be 1,543.
5,804 plus 0.
Once again, we're adding nothing
to it, so it's just 5,804.
What number can we add
to 1,893 to get to 0?
So we're going to have to
essentially take 1,893 away.
So the only number that we can
add that would take away 1,893
is negative 1,893.
This added to 1,893
is equal to 0.
Anything times 1 is going
to be that anything,
so it's going to be 7,360.
By what number can we
multiply 4,850 to get 1?
Well, we've already done this.
This is just going to be
1/4,850, and we are done.